China VAT Chinese activist Ai Weiwei is
one of the world's most famous artists
and he's not subtle in his work
throughout his career I Weiwei has
created art to inspire change and he's
known for taking a stand against the
Chinese government and symbols of state
power one of eyes latest American
exhibits has just made its East Coast
debut in Washington the work features
the portraits of nearly 200 activists
prisoners and free speech advocates
Errol Barnett is at the her Shore museum
with the building blocks of eyes art
Carol good morning good morning you are
looking at the first exhibit a Weiwei
has been able to see in person and
that's because during his debut here in
Washington the Chinese government kept
him from leaving the country that
experience led him to create works
highlighting other activists and to
bring attention to major human rights
issues so this is first time missing my
work here assembled by hand with
thousands of plastic Lego bricks
these 176 portraits cover 700 feet
around this ring-shaped museum some
names are familiar from controversial
whistleblowers Edward Snowden and
Chelsea Manning two civil rights giants
like Nelson Mandela and Martin Luther
King jr. others are lesser-known but
include freedom fighters imprisoned for
life after so many France will never get
her released on the day we met with AI
weiwei longtime friend Liu Xiaobo
was said to have been moved from prison
and held on medical parole because of
his deteriorating health what's your
reaction to that he believes China
should become a democratic society
that's all he did
in 2010 Liu and i Weiwei were both
stopped from traveling abroad after liu
became the first Chinese citizen awarded
the Nobel Peace Prize an honor he never
received in person but you say this
isn't about individual portraits the
entire installation is a portrait of
activism those are real people real
story he represents
the most bright ideas fighting for
freedom but the Lego made face of one
notable Chinese activist is missing his
own a 2008 earthquake in China's Sichuan
province killed at least 70,000 people
including more than 5,000 children
enraged I Wei Wei led a citizen's
investigation discovering low quality
building materials contributed to
student deaths he also gathered and
published the names of all the youngest
victims I was beaten by police resulting
in a cerebral hemorrhage which he also
documented in 2011 authorities put a bag
over eyes head while he waited for a
flight detaining him for 81 days I used
that experience as inspiration for this
music video and these dioramas with
God's watching his every move do you
feel that you've nudged the Chinese
government have you created change it's
very hard to measure I would not say in
the larger scale because I still think
this structure is quite a fragile in
what way in the way they have to censor
someone like me they're never sure if
they can be really winning if there's a
freedom of speech on Instagram I
documents just about everything he does
and everyone he meets he also posts
images without clothes on it too is a
response to censorship my name cannot
appear in Chinese social media and yeah
it's illegal words nobody can put my
name on social media and sometimes even
they see a photo of my backside they
can't recognize that's him they were
delete the whole article as we talked a
few miles from the White House I tells
me he's delighted by the social media
habits of its powerful resident I was
amazed or Chum
to see a president we covered midnight
entertains normally with Inka president
hold all the secrets will never tell you
what he thinks about it can be
controversy or can be unpredictable but
you're saying at the very least it's
authentic it is why he touches that
sending key it believes it's a good idea
to share it now what's interesting is
even after I was released from detention
he had to wait four years for the
Chinese government to return his
passport he now has an art studio in
Berlin and travels the world with his
eight-year-old son who by the way was
his inspiration for using a children's
toy as part of his work Gail thank you
they're really very provocative powerful
stuff yeah reminds as far as we've come
with a long way to go can't imagine what
it's like though David to be recognized
for your but what is that like No
very nicely done thank you Vera